ثم تبلغ إيران بأزمة خطيرة
في الخليج أن أزمة قطر
معكم
السعودية والبحرين وحليفتكم
مصر ، هل يمكن أن تؤدي هذه الأزمة إلى
مواجهة عسكرية لا بالتأكيد
لا أعني أنكم متأكدون من ذلك
أعتقد أن هناك  عدة أشياء أريد أن
أقولها أعتقد أن علي أكبر الله
خرج وقال إننا أنقذنا النظام القطري
ومن الواضح هنا يمكننا أن نرى
علاقات كوثري الإيرانية الأقرب
لكنني أعتقد أننا كنا نيتنا بشدة
وأعتقد أننا قلنا لك بوضوح  تعرف
بعد المحاولة التي تعرفها لمضايقة
بعض الخطوط الجوية المدنية فوق
المجال الجوي الدولي شمال قطر ،
لقد خرجنا وقلنا أن هذا ليس
ما نسعى إليه ، سنقوم
بمحاكمتك دون تدخل في
الطيران المدني وسنحاول
وإبعاد مناطق التدريب لدينا عن
المجال الجوي الخشبي إلى المزيد من الأجواء السعودية
لتجنب أن تكون حكومتك قد
حذرت بالفعل الجيش الإماراتي من تصعيد
هذه الأزمة التي قد يقترحها البعض
هل هي مهمة استفزازية أعرف أن
الجيش الإماراتي جزء من الحكومة ،
أعتقد أن الحكومة تقوم بالجيش
ولكن من الواضح أننا نعلم أن
كل شيء سيخرج وسيكون
واضحًا جدًا فيما يتعلق بالقضية مع
قطر  أنت تعلم أننا
نتوقع تغييرًا في السلوك
وأعتقد أنه بمجرد حدوث هذا التغيير في السلوك مع
الدوحة ، هذا هو الوقت الذي يمكننا فيه
بالفعل إعادة الاتصال مرة أخرى ولكن
أعتقد أن ATAR في موقف صعب ، أليس كذلك